[Music]
for some pet owners feeding raw food to
fido is a natural choice it harkens back
to the common ancestor of all dog breeds
the wolf in the wild wolves eat raw meat
and occasionally some greens so the
theory goes that dogs are genetically
predisposed to thrive on a raw meat diet
[Music]
dogs have been domesticated for
thousands of years but when it comes to
their diet they can still go a little
wild
raw canine cuisine may be a foreign
concept to some pet owners but it's
becoming more mainstream
the makers of raw dog food often mix
fruits and vegetables with meat to
provide fiber and create a balanced meal
the process starts with a lot of slicing
and dicing
[Music]
a food worker chops the fruits and
veggies into smaller pieces so they'll
be able to go through a grinder more
easily
[Music]
he also removes the seeds from the
apples in the squash because the seeds
aren't as easily digested as the rest of
the fruit and provide no additional
nutrition
[Music]
this raw pet food recipe calls for a
variety of fruits and vegetables
though in total they will comprise just
five percent of the meal
the rest of the raw blend will consist
of meat bones organs and fish
[Music]
another food worker chops up the chicken
which has been organically raised and
has even been approved for human
consumption
[Music]
except for the breasts all the parts of
the chicken will be used in the main
recipe this includes the heart liver
gizzards and the bones
raw whole sardines anchovies and
mackerel will add essential fatty acids
to the raw chicken blend
all the ingredients have been prepared
and are now ready for grinding
a worker feeds the components to the
grinder in small batches
interspersing the meat fish and the
vegetables
[Music]
this ensures even distribution as the
grinder minces everything to a uniform
particle size
[Music]
the result is a thick emulsion of finely
ground chicken meat bones vegetables
fruits and fish
[Music]
she transfers the minced raw ingredients
to a mixer
the revolving paddles further blend the
food
after about five minutes in the mixer
all the ingredients have been combined
into one homogenous raw mass
[Music]
this chicken blend is now complete
the worker divides it into five pound
batches and scoops it into bags
she vacuum seals the bag
removing all the air inside will allow
the raw blend to stay fresh longer
refrigerated it should last for up to 10
days and if frozen it should be good for
several months
for the furry members of the family
dinner is ready to be served
to make some raw pet snacks a worker
de-shells new zealand green-lipped
mussels a species that is believed to
have fast-acting
anti-inflammatory properties
after she cuts the mussels free from the
shells she places them on racks for air
drying
[Music]
she transfers the rack into a drying
tent where fans keep air circulating 24
hours a day
[Music]
as the muscles dry they shrink
after 72 hours in the tent the moisture
content is substantially reduced
air drying has preserved the flesh of
the muscles in the raw state while
preventing damage to the nutrients and
enzymes they contain
now preserved she packs the muscles into
plastic bags and adds an iron oxide
packet to absorb oxygen and prevent
spoilage
this raw pet food is now ready to
nourish the wolf in your dog
[Music]